oh hello lovely viewer of the slow mo
guys I'm gab I'm Dan we're the slow mo
guys see usually I don't say that first
bit and then hope you have to say it was
confusing what yeah this is a lovely
short little video I got myself here a
percussive massage device sort of like a
meet pulverizer another massager you
gonna give you a massage with that well
sort of sweet looks like a power tool
sounds like a power tool that's kind of
scary
my face with that do some of that in
slow-mo obviously all right expression
um you go for height let's keep your
face jolly and loose great yeah
do you know what I think happened there
right is you know at the bottom of your
eye you know it's like your noses that
you can see your notes yeah my cheek was
coming up into my eyeline I think it was
like shoot my cheek up into my eye
well yes Dan yes it is like a splash in
water it's like a stone dropping in your
face pond look is I'm completely still
relative to that bottom when I blink it
looks like I'm like a wax model like for
a stunt thing on TV you get empowered
how many punches per second is it it's
it's it's happening almost once a second
a thousand FPS it's probably close to 40
times a second all right so because I
was slightly worried about hurting you I
think you should do it to yourself
because you know the limits of it it'll
also do some extra face flap kinda like
the flappy face this video from like
seven years ago I'll do some I work I
work it some lip movement yeah maybe
there's spit if you can because the
screen is only updated several times I'm
just get like tons of free strains of
your face
[Laughter]
would you like hold a plastic bag
exactly what it looks like
ah love it I'm also more jolly than I
was when we first did that that's fair
yeah okay so angle slightly with the Sun
just to have less of his face in the
shade and there's a very zoomed in lens
on there now so it's gonna be like this
this is the framing I'm not sure I've
ever filmed you this close-up in 4k
before Oh yep I cut in and see my pores
yeah oh you really are close
oh this spit everywhere as well well
it's like going out of sync until now
oh he's like pushing my mouth sideways
from one side you are in Garry's Mod all
right any other well we've just done
sort of soggy cheek in a minute yeah I
see if I can hit the bone here and if it
like jiggles my eye sockets I might be a
bit painful so it might be a bit shorter
because I might be like getting punched
in the eye you might get a black eye
like my labels rattling your whole head
it's like bashing your skull like the
other eye you can see the eye fat like
underneath my eyes like jiggling it
aside could it whole front it's going
down to my gels and everything my nose
is being moved to look at the skins just
being compressed there it's like
squishing together give me wrinkles
nostril area the frenulum the friend.you
it's not quite a friendly that's not
ways we should do my nose we should do
your nose my nose
she sends it all around the other
nostril Oh your nose skin up to the
bridge is like being shoved oh well
see you exactly what my nose bone is
there's so much beyond my bone it's
literally doing this like yeah alright
damn what would you say is the fleshy
Esparta then we can show on YouTube
probably probably my like PEC or maybe
my gut okay we pop that kit it looks
like um my arm is actually connected to
my PEC completely just it's like war
sticking to it slightly it's like
output ah it's gross this might be jelly
that if you look at my back there I'm
relaxing in 10 to noon oh yeah let's try
that push against me
then it like shakes the whole of you
back you see they're so weird
he goes from like sheep [ __ ] like like
water rippling along you to just
jiggling the entire muscle
yeah the muscles up and then it becomes
like their complete solid object yeah
rattling your whole back it's almost
like it's like the outside is riffle and
then the middle part is like a solid
slab just getting shoved around well dan
I think we've learned a lot about your
face and head and body and things fully
massage now nice and tender yeah it was
actually really cool when you flex the
muscle because instead of just sending
ripples through like a puddle it was
like you were you're moving a whole
steak like your back like the skin
locked up and it moved the entire thing
rather than like a ripple very weird
that and the sky like I almost want to
use this for another video I made with
liquids or something get sort of like a
speaker yeah yeah some Oobleck hopefully
you enjoyed that video feel free to
subscribe to the slow mo guys and follow
us on social media and stuff and we'll
see you right back here in the next
video Gucci